よろしくお願いします
今日は浄心処というところで 25種類あります
パーリ語だったら これはソーヴァナチェータシカですね
ソーヴァナチェータシカ
まあソーヴァナっていうのは
まあ一般的なパーリ語だったらビューティフルという意味なんですよ
美しいという意味なんです
いわゆる良いといういいという意味でその言葉使ってるんです
で 日本では浄心処と清らかな心所という風に訳してます
で 善不善という風に分けると
善心所 善悪に人間の行動を分ける場合は
これは善というカテゴリに入ります
良いものと悪いものと分ける場合は
で 25あります 不善心所は 14でしたけど
これの場合は 25なんですね
で その中でちょっと哲学的に思想的に喋る場合は
この一つ言えるのは心が悪くする
心は堕落する心所は 14しかないんです
心が成長するということになると 25種類入ってる
たくさん入ってるんですね
ということは 我々の心を成長するということを成長しようと思えば
いくらでも成長できるんです
そちらにもリミットがありますけど
それ以上はできないというリミットがありますけど
で 悪くなると言っていえば
まあそれでどこどこまでも悪くなるということはないんですね
まあある程度でリミットがあるんです
そこであの 簡単に言えば
我々の心はやっぱり不善心所の方に
不善の方に 普通の人間の心がだいたいだいたい不善心所の方にあるんです
で 生きているということで
我々この眼耳鼻舌身 喜ばせること
刺激を受けることは生きることになっているんですね
目で刺激を受けて 耳で鼻で
口で 体で刺激を受けているんです
それから頭でいろんなものを考えて刺激を受けているんですね
誰も気が付いてないんだけど
結局生きているということは刺激を求めていることなんですね
だから一瞬も刺激なしに生きていられないんですね
刺激が入ったら心は新しい波動を作っちゃうんですね
それの波動で もう刺激によってその波動がなくなろうとすると
また新しい刺激を入れてあげるんですね
だから結局心の栄養っていうのは刺激なんですね
我々に刺激っていうのは
眼耳鼻舌身意というこの 6つのチャネルからいろんな刺激が入っているんです
ですから だいたいみんなこの死ぬのが怖くて
死ぬのは嫌とか思ったり
心配したりするんだけど
結局刺激ある限りは心は停止することはないんです
刺激ない瞬間一つもないんです
そういうことで 輪廻っていうのは確実に転生して転換して変えて変えていくんです
仏教でいう輪廻 輪廻転生というのは
この一般的な俗的な考えているような大胆な変化ではないんです
ここで生きて死んで死んだらどこに生まれ変わりますか？と考えるのは仏教的な考え方ではないんですね
それは他の宗教で考えて輪廻転生で仏教で言ってる輪廻転生というのはものすごい簡単なもので
心は瞬間瞬間刺激を受けて新しい心が生まれるんですね
ですから 輪廻転生というのは今すでにあるものなんです
我々は今すでにも死んで生まれて生まれ変わるんですよ
例えば ある刺激があった時は
怒りが怒りの心が生まれると
その時は怒りの心しかない
その時は怒りの人間なんですね
怒りの心を持ってる人間であって
それでその刺激 その対象がなくなったら
怒りの心はどんどん消えてしまって
違う心が生まれるんですね
その時も我々は質的にも人間は全く違うんだと
体の物質さえ違うんですね
例えば怒りがある場合は体も違うんです
その代わりに喜びが生まれたら
また体が違うんです 我々の感じでは同じ体ではないかとただ勘違いしているだけなんですね
で 同じものを我々にいろんなものに作られるんですね
例えば あの 何と言いますか
何か壺を作るんだと 壺を作る場合は
どんな材料でも壺というものは作られるんですね
木材でも彫って作られるし
土でも作られる 土もいろいろありますし
それで作られる それはいろんな方法で釉薬を塗って焼いたりすることもできるし
だからその使っている材料によって
壺は本当は違うものなんですけど
同じ形の同じ模様の壺は
いろんな材料で作られるんです
それは金属でも作られるし
そこで金で作った壺だったら大変高価なもので
木か土で作ったものはそれほど価値がないものになるだけのことで
ですから体っていうのは
そういう壺のようなある同じ形作ってるんですね
でも怒りが生まれたら
この体の質という内容は違うんです
喜びが生まれたらまた違う体なんですね
我々は形見て壺の形は同じから同じ壺だといきなり決めてしまう
それは良くないと それは智慧がないんだからそう思ってるだけですよと言ってるんですね
仏教によると ですから
輪廻転生というのは 今すでに我々は輪廻転生しているんです
心が変わるたびに全部変わって新しいものになってしまっちゃうんですね
そのあまりの速さですからね
それわからないんですね
ですから この今スリランカでも大変問題になっている
この問題になってますけども
何年間からも誰も答えられないだからもうなんかずっとウロウロしている問題がありまして
この中という概念 それは大乗仏教で大変人気ある概念で
人が死んでからもう確定した場所に生まれ変われるまで間があるんだと
それは中というんですね
原文でアンターラーババというんですね
そのアンターラーババっていうのは
この中 ありますかないかという問題があって
何か自分の国でもなんかあるような感じで
いろいろ人々は喋ってる
でもテーラワーダ仏教では中という概念がないんです
で テーラワーダ仏教というのは
人が死んだらすぐ生まれ変われるんだと
瞬間に あっという間 もう生まれ変わってるんだと
またもう考えて もう人間みたいにどうしようああしようとかね
悩んだり そんなことはないんだと
心の場合 瞬間にもう次の生がもう構成されますというのはテーラワーダの考え方
で なかなかそれ他の仏教では認めないんですね
認めないで 中はあるんだと
と言ってるんです テーラワーダの概念というのは
この心は瞬間瞬間生まれ変わっていくんですね
瞬間瞬間生まれるために新しい刺激が入ればいいんです
刺激っていうのは波動であって波なんですね
光にしても固まって光をするわけじゃなくて
粒子一つ一粒一粒目に触れるんです
ですから 目に触れる触れるたびに新しい視覚が生まれて生まれて
流れていくんですね 光が流れて目に入る
そうすると視覚も同じ流れとして生まれていくんですね
音も音という何か物体あるわけじゃないんですね
音というエネルギーの流れ
そのエネルギーの流れが目に触れるたびに
聴覚という心が生まれて生まれて
新しい心の流れがここに生まれる
ここで音という音という流れがぶつかると
ここのここに心という流れが生まれて流れていくんですね
で そういうふうに心が流れると
心の構成によって体に影響を与えて
体も変わっていくんですよ
で そのその次元で物事を考えないと
宙の概念が生まれてくるんですね
ここに私がいるんだと
私に個体的な体があるんだと
個体として心もあるんだと
という それ 仏教で言えば邪見なんですね
悟りの第 1 段階で その邪見を破ることは預流果というんですね
個体はないと 全部流れていくものだと
その体験に預流果というんですね
その体験が現れたら もう他の概念
他の宗教 他のものが言っていることのは
どこまで間違いが明確に見えてしまうんですよ
だから私はよく言うのは
預流果になるということは
ある一種の超越した哲学者になることですよと
預流果になった人は ものすごい優れている哲学者なんですね
でも 頭だけ動かす哲学者ではなくて
まあ性格としても哲学者であって
ものは見えているんですね
その人は だからといって怒りがないとか
欲がないわけじゃないんです
それはまあありますけど
でも個体として私がいる
他人がいるという概念はない
無常であることはもうしっかりともう掴まってるんです
全てが それで流れてくる物質が現に物質に物質は流れてきて
物質はとてもエネルギーですね
波動ですね 流れてくると
心の中にもそれにふさわしい心の波動が
波が生まれていく そのスピードが変わらないんですね
音のスピードは変わらないし
光のスピードも変わらないし
それで心のスピードも変わらないんですね
ですから まあ今すでにも死んで生まれて死んで生まれていくんではないかと
そうすると ある時はこの体にこの心が機能できなくなる
できなくなっても 次の瞬間に心がまた生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
なぜならば 心にはいつでも刺激がいくらでもあるんです
我々心配しなくてもいくらでもあるんです
人間が欲に溺れてるんだから
もう何かやることないかとすっごく落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
刺激がないと落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
それは強烈な刺激を欲しがってるだけのことで
ものすごい大胆な強烈な刺激求めて走ってるだけ
でもいつでも刺激があるんです
例えばやることなくなっちゃったら落ち込む
落ち込むこともかなりの刺激なんです
落ち込んだ人にはもう 1ヶ月間でも 1年
2年  3年でも落ち込んでいることはできるんです
で うつ病になったら それは落ち込むの一つの現象ですけど
これ 1年  2年じゃないんですよ
なかなかそれ破って他の波を作ることさえ難しいんです
それぐらいその刺激にもう何て言いますか
惹かれてしまうんですよ
寝ることも刺激なんですよ
ですから刺激ない瞬間はないんです
そういうことで心が死んでもすぐすぐ生まれる
だから今私が怒って怒るために
例えば何か聞いてすぐ怒るでしょうに
瞬間に それもっと早く我々は死んだら生まれ変わりますよ
怒る場合も我々瞬間に怒るんだけど
怒る場合は時間かかるんですよ
聞いたことを頭で解釈しなきゃ起こらないんですね
ですから解釈してから結果として怒りますから
でも我々は瞬間に怒ったと勘違いするだけで
ですから それより早いんですね
人が死んだらすぐ生まれ変わるということ
ですから 仏教でこのテーラワーダ仏教で宙がないというのは
この素粒子レベルで波動のレベルで存在のことを考えているんだからなんです
個体として考えていないんだから
特に大乗仏教っていうのは
この仏神 仏僧 仏性 ああだこうだとか言って
この個体みたいな我みたいなものを考えてしまっちゃったんですね
でも大乗仏教でも我を認めているということはないんだけど
言葉上では口先では我はないと
無我ですよと苦ですよと徹底的に言うんだけど
大乗仏教で言ってる苦自体が我なんです
苦の説明聞くと いろんな苦のランクがありますたりして
最終的には真理そのものを苦と言ったりして
そこはもう我の概念なんですね
抜けてないんです だから哲学的にはいくら頭を動かしても
この修行しない限りは
この無我であることは理解できない
それは一つの体験なんですね
人間が普通体験するのは有を体験する
有と無 両方体験して 全ては有と無の流れですよと体験するためには
特別に修行というものは必要になっちゃうんです
訓練が必要になっちゃう
だから訓練なしに考えると
やっぱりうろんで終わってしまう
その話は難しいんですけどね
一応テーラワーダ仏教では中有はない
ないというのは この瞬間生滅変化する
物事はすべて瞬間瞬間生滅変化していきますよというところから言っているもので
お釈迦様も中有ありますよという言葉は言ってない
経典にも出てこない ですから
このただ部派仏教の時代で考えたことなんですね
その考えたことを 例えば人間が死にましたと
それでまた他のところでまた人間として生まれ変わりましたよといったところで
そこで間があると じゃあ 1 年間どこにいたんですか？とかね
それは中有ではないかとか計算することはできるかもしれません
テーラワーダではたった一つの質問をするんです
中の場合は 中有は欲界か色界か無色界かと
いわゆる生命が生まれる次元は 3つに分けているんですね
輪廻の中で色界 無色界
欲界 色界 無色界と 欲界っていうのは体がある世界
色界っていうのは瞑想している梵天の世界で
無色界っていうのは体存在しない次元感
その 3つに分けているんですね
欲界の場合は体があって
眼耳鼻舌身から情報刺激を受ける
色界の場合は体があるんだけど
刺激には眼耳鼻舌身の刺激には耐えない
禅定状態で生きている
無色界っていうのは 体はない
心だけの次元 じゃあその 3次元でどちらに入りますかと
中有は ただその中有を考えた人々は
それをどっちにも入れませんと言うんです
もっと入りますよと言ったら
そうすると中でなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると次の質問は
じゃあ色界 無色界 欲界
色界 無色界以外 存在の次元がありますか？とお釈迦様がおっしゃったんですから
存在の次元はいくつありますか？と言ったら
3つですよと言うんです
それを誰でも認めるんです
大乗仏教も小乗仏教もどっちに
そうすると中有は色界でも無色界でも欲界でもないというならば
中有はないでしょうと
ですから あなた方の考え方は理屈に合わないんだと否定しちゃうんです
で この物質の存在と心の存在はありのままわかると
中有っていうのはありえないということは見えるんですね
[背景音楽]で で 仮に住む場所っていうのはないんです
本当はどこでも仮に住んでいても
人間の世界で我々はせいぜい 80年ぐらいいるだけであって
これは我々のもう徹底した住み住み家ではないんです
輪廻はすごい長いんだから
もう何光年単位でもう無数ですからね
生きてるし ですから ある 1箇所でも 100年
10年  20年 あるいは 1万年
84万年とか まあそれぐらいのいるだけのことであって
どこでも仮の住まいなんです
人間の生命も仮の住まいであって
ですから 中っていうのはもう考えても有り得ないと
その考え方出たのは このこの仏教で言ってる餓鬼道の存在なんですね
この餓鬼道っていうところは
あの餓鬼といったらなんかちょっとおかしい言葉ですけど
パーリ語でペータと言うんですね
ペータっていうのは これヒンドゥー教
以前このブラフマン教
バラモン教あったんですね
バラモン教ではピートルという言葉があったんです
こういう感じで入れて
この R は母音なんです
ですから ピートルと発音するわけです
ピートル まあ発音難しいかもしれませんね
このピートルというのは
この英語でもファーザーという言葉がありますね
その同じ言葉なんです
ラテン語でパティーンという言葉ありますね
その同じ父という意味なんですね
だからこのピートル世界があるんだと
いわゆる我々の人々 我々のね
まあ死ぬのは年の人々ですから
死んだ人々は まあその死んだ人々の世界があるんだという概念が昔あったんです
そういうのは一般的な宗教であって
この仏教みたいな この超越した知恵で発見した真理ではないんです
人間のただの考え方 人が亡くなったところで
私たちのおじいちゃんがおばあちゃんがそのおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちの世界に行きましたと
ピートルのまあ戦争の世界に行きましたとという概念がありまして
そこでどんどん変化して
死んだ人が行く世界という風にどんどん言葉
概念が変化したんですね
お釈迦様の時代になってくると
まあ父の世界というよりは
まあ死後の世界というところまで言葉
概念が変化していたんですね
お釈迦様はその言葉を取って
生命のある次元を示すためにその言葉を使ったんですね
仏教では梵天があって
天界がありまして 人間界があります
地獄がありますたりとか分けているんですね
その中でこの地獄のランクに入る
まあ一部をペータの世界だと
ペータっていうのは英語ではディパーターという意味なんですね
ディパーチャー ディパーっていうのは出て行ったという意味ですね
パーっていうのは部分分かれたディっていうのは強調の言葉で
それを動詞としてディパーテッド
過去分詞として使ってるんですね
ディパーテッド まあまあ戦争って意味なんですね
一般の日本語で だからペータっていうのは餓鬼道と言ったっても
これ戦争の世界って意味なんですね
この この世界で この戦争の世界で
いろんな生命がいろんな次元
いろんな生き方があって
それ簡単に分けてるんです
それ分けた方はこのチクセという動物の世界はすごい狭くてわかりやすい
それでこの地獄というこの苦しみだけ
徹底的に苦しみだけ刺激にして生きている次元があります
それは地獄と言ってるんですね
で それをそういう風に分け方難しい世界はディパーテッド世界と
この戦争の世界と言ってるんですね
そこら辺のなんかこの理解の問題で
この中が出てきたんではないかなと思います
例えばある人が中がありますよと証拠を出しても
テーラワーダ世界から言えば
それはペータ次元の存在ですよと
ペータという次元の存在ですよとしか言えないんですね
もっとわかりやすく言えばこれ理解できると思いますけどね
まあいろいろ証拠はあるんですね
亡くなった人が何かどこかにいるような感じがしましたとかね
見えましたとか あるいは誰かに乗り移ったとかね
そういういろいろ人間の中でいろんな考え方あるんですね
亡くなった人がちゃんと自分を守っているんだとかね
あるいはまあ それは全部嘘だと捨てることは難しいし
例えばまあ どこかへ旅に出ようと思ったところで
夜自分の亡くなったおじいちゃんかおばあちゃんが出てきて
その行くなとか何とか言われたんだと
そこで自分がそれをやめたところで
その旅に出た他の人々はすごい事故を起こしちゃって死んじゃったとかね
やっぱり自分をおじいちゃんにもちゃんと守ってくれたんだとか
それでもうみんなそう思ったり考えたりする
で 幽霊が出たとか お化けが出たという概念というのはどんな国にもあるんですよ
ですから この人間というのはなんだかんだでっちあげた上がった話作るのもなかなか難しいんです
何かあって それにストーリー作っちゃうんですよ
ストーリー自体は嘘かもしれませんだけど
もう何かあったこと 何かあったと思うことも可能なんですね
何かあったことについてストーリーが作ったと
だから我々はいつでもストーリーばっかり作る
例えば今 最近亡くなったダイアナさんのお話に至っても
あるのは全部ストーリーばっかり作った
でっちあげたストーリーばっかりで
事実はどうかと誰もわからない
本人直接喋ったりすることもほとんどないし
でも 例えばどこから遠くから 100メートル
200 300 400 メートル遠くから写真を撮ったとかね
それでこういうこういうことだとストーリー作る
例えば撮った写真に二人が写っている可能性はありますよ
一人はダイアナさんで
もう一人は他の人で でもどんな関係で
何のためにそこにいるかどうかはさっぱりわからない
それは全部もう記者がストーリーを作るんです
我々生きている世界というのは全部ストーリーの世界でね
事実の世界ではないんですね
ですから こういうガキの幽霊の話にしても
なんかちょっと音を聞いたとかね
何かドアが開けた音とかね
何かあったらそれでストーリー作ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから ストーリー自体は一応置いといたとしても
何か原因があって そういうストーリーができるということも言えることは言えるんですね
そこでこの では 私もいろいろテキストを読んだところで
この輪廻転生の証拠ですか
証拠を探して ちゃんと研究して比較して書いている本もあります
だからいるんです いるんですね
たまに子供たちが生まれて
自分の過去生を喋る 私は過去でああいうところにいましたとかね
そういう風に喋る場合は
この喋る情報は全部記録するんです
お母さんはどんな人ですか？とか
お父さんはどんな人ですか
どこにいたんですか？とか
親戚はどうどうでしたとか
そういう全部情報を取って
もしこの最近のこと 何 100年前のことを言うと
もうどうしてもじゃないんだからね
最近のことを言う場合は
その場所に行って全部確かめてみるんですね
結構そういうケースはあるんです
人が死んですぐ人間として生まれ変わるってところで
子供がよく言うのは 私のうちはこっちじゃないんだとかね
そうするとこの そういう
まあ日本だったら それはあんたおかしいことを言うなとか抑えちゃいますけど
例えば仏教の世界だったら
あまりそういうふうに抑えることをしないんですね
ただ じゃああなたのうちはどこですかとか
冗談で聞くんですね 聞くと
まあお母さんも別に遊んでるかもしれませんだけど
子供はこういうこういうところだ
こういうこういうところだ
私にも子供いましたとか
ああだこうだ言っちゃうと
あ これちょっと違うんだと
それで全部そういうのは記録して
そういう場所に行って探しちゃう
探したところで結構だいたい 70%以上行ったことは合う場合は
この人は過去生でそこにいた可能性はあるんだと
いたかどうかなんではなくて
この人言ってるこの子供が何も情報なしに言ってることが 70%以上成功しているんだと
ですから 説明はどんな説明でもいいというふうに
このテキストをいくつか書いているんです
その場合 一つは計算してみるんですね
その人が死んだ時とか
いつ死んだか ここで子供がいつ生まれたかって
それはちゃんと計算できますからね
その時はかなり時間の間が見つかっちゃうんですね
例えばお腹に入ったら 10ヶ月ですし
死んですぐ生まれ変わったならば
死んだ日からちゃんと計算して 10ヶ月でないと
10ヶ月でなくてもね
9ヶ月でもいいんだけど
もうその間ちゃんと計算合わなくちゃいけないんだけど
やっぱり 1年  2年  5年とか
間が出ちゃうんですね
それでこれは中陰ではないかとね
と思ったりはする まあそういうことで中陰の考え方はなんか人気出てきているような感じですけど
でもテーラワーダのちゃんとした教えからいうと
そんなあるわけがないんです
で 間があったら その間で他の次元でその生命がいたっていうことだけなんですね
それはこのペータの次元なんですね
このペータの次元でもいろいろペータがいるし
人間界に戻りたく戻りたく
その希望は強い 強いんだけど
それで人間界に戻れるぐらい徳もある
徳もあって希望強いんだけど
ちょっと待たなくちゃいけないんですね
ここに どこかにお母さんのお腹に入るまでは
その間なんですね でも待ってはいるかもしれませんだけど
それもちゃんとした生命ですよというのが我々の考え方なんですね
たとえ 1週間であろうとも
それは 1週間の生命で
そこで寿命終わったら他のところで生まれ変わると
ですから 大したことないんだけどね
まああんまり中陰中陰と言っちゃうと
ちょっと仏教論理学的には問題が生まれてくる
それを商売にする可能性もある
ですから まあそういうことで
テーラワーダ 伝統的なテーラワーダ世界は結構気をつけるんですね
で このペータ次元に 次元の中にいるある一部の生命に
この人間とコンタクト取れるんです
ある一部だけ みんなにできない
その人間とコンタクト取れる人々はコンタクトを取るんです
なんとかの形で この回向する場合も
この誰でも亡くなったら我々回向するんですね
この これは仏教でよくやることで
7日とかね  49日目とかなんとかして法事をやって
で それを法事やってるのは日本ですけど
我々も法事みたいなものをやりますけど
回向するんですね 徳を積んで
その徳を向こうに与えるんですね
もらってくださいと その回向する場合は
この我々が行った行為の結果が得られるのは
このコンタクト取れる次元だけなんです
例えば私の誰かが お母さんでも叔父ちゃん誰かが亡くなって天界に生まれ変わったら
天界 あんまり人間とはコンタクト取らない
回向したっても受けないんです
あるいは私のおじいちゃんが他のアフリカとかどうかで生まれ変わったといて
こちらで回向したって
まるっきり知らないんだからね
この人は アフリカに生まれたのはアフリカ人だからね
そちらの文化に馴染んで生活しているし
仏教ということの話も知らないかもしれませんしね
そういう回向したっても
その徳は行かないんですね
だからそんな話を言うと
なんかちょっと商売にならないみたいんですね
ということは 私はおじいちゃんに回向しません
法事はやりませんと人が言ったら
それはダメですよ ちゃんと法事やりなさいということは言えないんですね
そういうことで 確実に中陰がありますよとかね
必ず回向しなさいとかね
ちゃんと法事やりなさいとかは言ってるんです
そこは別な話で 論理的な本当の仏教の話とは違うんです
それはまあ普通の世界で
商売の世界の話で で その話をお釈迦様は正直に言ってるんですよ
そういう他人に他人から与える徳を受け入れられる可能性ある次元だけ
我々の徳を受けて それそのエネルギーでいいところに生まれ変われますよと
他の人々には関係ないんだと
他の生命には ですから
確実に自分の亡くなった母親のために一生懸命法事やっても
亡くなった母親は必ずしもその徳を受けるということはないんです
受けるかもしれません
受けないかもしれません
その話はなかなか一般仏教の世界で言うと
ちょっと人気がないというか
まあ危ないというか どっちか
そういうことで この中部の話がそういう人気が出てきているんです
でもお釈迦様はこう言うんですよ
回向する場合は 自分の先祖ということで制限を決めないで
お父さんにお母さんにとか決めないで
自分の亡くなった人々みんなにあげますよという風に
無制限に回向してくださいと
だから原因は自分の母が亡くなった 1週間目になりました
それで法事を行う 法事を行うのはメイン原因は自分の母親かもしれませんだけど
回向する場合は母親と他のすべての先祖みんなに回向しますと
と もう無制限に回向しなさいと
そうすると確実に自分の徳が誰かが受けるんだと
その場合は確実だと なぜかというと
輪廻を我々の徳は大きいというとあまりにも大きいんですね
ですから この回向を受けられる次元に自分の親戚
誰もいないということはないんだと
いるんです 誰かが この徳を回向しますというと
受けられる生命が確実にいるんです
それは自分の母親父親というふうには限ってはないんです
ですから 誰かが亡くなっても
亡くならなくても 習慣として回向しなさいと
ですから テーラワーダ仏教ではこの回向の文句っていうのはあります
短い文句ですけど イダン メーナーティーナ ホートゥというほんの短い文句ですけど
誰でもそれは朝晩言うんです
誰か死ぬまで待たないんです
何かいいことをしたら
すぐそれを先祖にも回向します
こちらで作っている回向の文句にも
いつでももう自分の先祖とかね
みんなに入れているのはそういうわけで入れたんです
瞑想してもそれはいいことだから
それも回向しますと いいことをしたらそれも回向しますと
そうすると 特別に死者の儀礼としてではなくて
日常生活の一つの宗教活動としてテーラワーダ仏教では回向するんです
大乗仏教だったら それはある特別な死者儀礼になっているんですね
それはあんまり意味がないと我々の立場から言ってるんです
それは日常の習慣としてやるものであると
なんで中部の話になったかというと
国の影響かもしれませんけど
まだ向こうのショックが抜けてないんです
昨日来たばっかりだから
[笑い]で で 心がこの人間の心の次元が堕落する
神数は十四しかないし
それでこういうあの四つの地獄餓鬼道畜生
それから阿修羅ですか
その四つと人間界 そのどちらかで生まれ変われる
心は清らかになる場合は
人間界から天界 梵天界とかいろいろなところに上々まで行ける
さらに神数が善心数成長しちゃうと出世間心生まれて解脱することもできる
ですから成長する場合は二十五種類の心相がありまして
まあ堕落する場合は十四しかない
ですから一つの明るいメッセージなんですね
頑張ればいくらでも人間には成長できると
我々はこの doom nation ではなくて
いわゆるなんていうの
doom っていうのはこの
もう  なんていうか 運命は決めてもう悪くなる運命に決められている
どうしようもないものではなくて
どんな生命にでも成長する可能性はいつでもあります
成長不可能ということはないと
ということを まあ基本的にメッセージとして伝えたいという気持ちでもあるんですね
ですから たまに人が何か悪いことをしちゃったら
あの人ダメやとかね そういう風に決めたがるんですね
人間っていうのは何か悪いことをしたら
まあその人は人生は全部ダメだとかね
ちょっと子供たちでもちょっとどこか不良のグループに入ったとか
まああの子はもう全部人生終わりとかね
そういう風に決めつける必要はないんです
で 立ち直る可能性はいくらでもあるんです
いくらでもあるんです
ですから とにかく仏教を考える人々は
とにかく人生は空でありますよというふうに言ってますけど
やっぱりいつでも明るいアプローチでいなくちゃいけない
ああ 全ては苦しみだから
まあ嫌だ ダメだとかね
どうしようもないんだとか
落ち込むための教えではないんです
それを間違って考えるとそうなっちゃうんですよ
何やっても意味がないんだとかね
まあどっちにだって無常だからとかね
で 空だからとか言ったりしてるのは
それはあまり仏教的じゃないんです
とにかく明るく もう成長しようではないかというふうなアプローチ
すごく大事にしているんです
ですから このテーラワーダだけの世界の人間というのは
もう何があろうとも明るさあるんですよ
どんな不幸にあっても
まあ結構明るく頑張ろうではないかという気持ちだけはあるんです
で 宗教に走ったら みんなだいたいこの先進国々ではみんな暗く
なんかすごく暗くなっちゃうんです
宗教捨てて何かやる人々はすごい元気で頑張っちゃうし
それは違う 間違ってる道で
で 向こうだったら宗教に走る人に限ってものすごくわかるんです
すごい活発的で 社会のためにも
人々のためにも 家のことも何でももう元気でやる
責任果たす 逃げようとしない
問題から ですから この宗教に対するアプローチは
この我々の国と先進国々では違うんです
先進国々で見えるのは
この逃げる人々 社会で行動できなくて
もう何かいろんなトラブルがあって
何か精神的な問題があって
うまくいかない それで宗教に逃げる
駆け込み寺ですね 宗教っていうのは
それは先進国々だけに見えてくるもので
他の国でもないわけ 完全にないわけないんだけどね
で ですからこの 無常は無常ですけど
全ては何やっても苦し空であることは確かですけど
だからといって落ち込んじゃったら
もう何も成長なくて 悪い次元だけでぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるだけですから
頑張って頑張って心を成長しちゃうと
どんどん超次元的に人間が成長して
そうしたっても輪廻の中だから
とにかく出世間心が生まれて解脱しよう
その解脱という概念が出て
解脱を目指して徹底的に努力するというのが仏教の教えであって
それは解脱するためには人間は完璧にならなくちゃいけない
完全な性格を作らなくちゃいけない
それを我々はパーラミターですか
波羅蜜という言葉で徳を進むとか
いろんな言葉で言ってるんですね
で みんなに優しくするとかね
自然に優しく 自分の周りの人々に大変優しくとかね
いろんな行動したり 人を助けたり
生命を助けたりとか 自分持っているものに欲張らないでみんなに配ったりとか
それからもう知恵をどんどん成長するようないろんな努力をしたりとか
で とにかく自分が女性で生まれても
男性で生まれても どんな形で生まれても
それに関係なく そのその自分の役目をちゃんと果たす完璧な人間になることも
基本的な条件として必要なんですよ
人生の問題に立ち向かう勇気もない人が
森の中に逃げて瞑想してもあまり成功しないんです